foreign
is going to start us off this hour and
he is in Atlanta hi Mario how are you
I'm doing better than I deserve as USA
Dave I'm doing great glad to be on the
show we're honored to have you sir how
can we help
um so the big the big point is um I'm
fairly new I'm not new to you but fairly
new to the show and I'm really on fire
and on board about just becoming
financially free uh debt free
um the teachings that you and your team
teach are phenomenal and my big question
is I want to know the best way to get my
wife on board with implementing some of
the drastic changes that we would need
to to make in order to get to that point
um I make a pretty good I have a strong
income
um the the I know all of our debt areas
I know the areas that you know where I
feel like we're you know spending too
much or over indulging but I know that
I'm gonna get some resistance with the
changes that we're going to need to make
in order to get to where I know that we
can get to give me an example of one of
the changes that you think you need to
make that you think you're going to get
resistance on
um
some areas of convenience like going out
to eat a lot or or ordering food how
much data a lot of
including house
okay uh credit card debt I met about
fifteen thousand dollars credit card
debt uh student loans total
um around 75 000.
um and I have one car that's not I have
one car that's not completely paid off
and I think we owe 12 000 on that car
and what's your household income
uh 175. okay yeah it's a great income so
Mario what's your what what's causing
you to
believe that she's going to have a hard
time with all of this is it comments
she's made is it something that in your
head you just know her and you're you
know you know what's going to be coming
has she given you Clues on it like I
want to know oh oh yeah yeah yeah
absolutely I come and she's made there's
other things that I've so
then for her in these conversations
what's the what what are her hesitations
um a lot of it has to do with our kids
okay okay
um so like for instance
um
I'll say okay hey we've completely paid
off this particular credit card we're
not going to use it we're going to put
it up interest rate is high on this
thing it doesn't make sense to plan
somebody to borrow from my future self
you know I do all of that and she's like
great sounds good uh but then time will
go on and I'll see charges on the credit
card and then when I say hey what
happened here why did this take place
and it was like oh I had to do this I
had to make this decision and do this
and you know yeah and so it's just kind
of like you know these things
a lot of times it's with the girls yes
you know my kids sure and and it's life
right because you guys have not put
systems in place for life to look
different so you're still keeping the
credit card we're gonna put this credit
card over here we shouldn't touch it but
it's still there get rid of it get rid
of it uh you guys do you guys have a
written budget that you have together
sharing an account saying hey here's
here's the line item for the kids this
is what we're gonna spend on the kids
here's the line I don't for you me food
out to eat clothes here's where every
single dollar this month is going I've
done all of that no have you guys
together no Mario have you guys together
done that we have we done that or have
you done that
so
I I have done it and I've shared it and
it's communicated this looks good I'm on
board let's do it let's run this plan
and we'll start running the plan and
okay totally so Mario I also think
I'm sure Ramsey has become a cuss word
in your house because a little bit of me
I'm fearful that you're using this
against her because I don't believe your
wife is malicious I think she's a great
mom probably a great wife and so so
these things life is just happening to
her and she's reacting obviously not in
the way that you prefer or that even
what we would teach right she's going
charging the credit card but it's not
malicious and so
um so I think that there needs to be a
higher level conversation to say okay
you and I together as a couple where do
we want to be what do we want life to
look like in five years what do we want
um are what what is our why like does
does she have any level of
pain or stress around money is she
worried in any way like I want you guys
to yeah
yeah for the most part
the weights on you don't want to have to
work until I retire 100 totally and
right now I'm the I'm the listen listen
she's a homie you're treating her like
she's your teenage daughter
she's not a partner and she's not a
partner in any of this
you're just bringing the budget and
laying it down giving some instructions
about a credit card and then you're
shocked that she didn't do what you told
her to do she's not a partner right
that's right you need to get above this
and the two of you need to sit down with
the kids away or the kids in bed and say
we have a hundred and two thousand
dollars in debt we make 175 000 that
makes us stupid people we need to change
some stuff here we're broke and we make
175 000 a year we have got to as a
couple aim at something bigger than kids
clothes Lord Jesus really yeah okay and
so we've got to have a big plan that
we're going at now honey I know I know I
know but this is him and his wife
talking okay yes we have to get on the
same page I do not want to be your daddy
I don't want to be your daddy I I I I
want to be your husband and I need I
need like a grown woman beside me
helping me make decisions about our few
future she needs an input in all of that
and then she gets input that she gets to
say and then by God when she gives input
it's a contract yes yes but she has no
reason she has no contract with you now
because you dictated it to her and
walked away and then we're shocked that
she went and bought kids clothes on a
credit card
because she had nobody right she had no
buy-in none whatsoever she didn't have a
voice in this and she has no belief in
the overall Vision she was just going
along with you yes and I would say this
too just as an encouragement Mario that
the conversations that I feel like
Winston and I the best conversations we
have around money is not really even
about money it's more like hey let's
just dream and in five years what do we
want our life like how how old are the
girls gonna be uh what kind of car do we
want to drive what vacations do we take
what do we want to be giving to in
general like allow your numbers then to
motivate you to your goals together as a
couple where you guys both want to go
and then the day-to-day plays into that
but kind of that there's a I'm looking
at her I'm going I make 175 000 a year
I'm really not okay with us being broke
all of that yeah every bit of that but I
think you got to say look we're sloppy
yeah we're disorganized yes yes we're
fat
what can we do to help you we're live
what can we do together to fix this